bonjour à tous j'ai toujours pensé que
la passion devait être au coeur de
chacun de nos projets de nos idées de
nos ambitions et vous voyez je vais
commencer en illustrant avec une petite
histoire quand j'étais plus jeune quand
j'avais 13 ans mes bandes ont fait un
numéro de Picsou Magazine à mon avis
tout le monde connaît ici et du coup
j'ai commencé en fait à découvrir
l'histoire de ce fantastique canard qui
est qui vivait en Écosse à déménager en
Amérique en fait avait pour objectif
d'aller à la fois faire fortune
découvrir le monde vivre à la fois de
nouvelles ambiances de nouveaux projets
et en fait marquer marqué véritablement
parce qu'il fait et du coup au fil du
temps j'ai découvert son histoire et sa
mentalité m'a beaucoup inspiré c'est
pour ça que je vous partage maintenant
parce qu'au final Picsou quand on y
réfléchit bien c'est quelqu'un qui est
parti vraiment de nulle part dans une
famille qui était très pauvre il n'avait
pas forcément les avantages ni en fait
les relations pour faire vraiment
quelque chose de solide et de du hard et
du coup en fait petit à petit il s'est
élevé il s'est élevé il a il a fait des
choix il a pris des risques il a tenté
de nouveaux projets et pour moi en fait
tout a démarré quand il a décidé de
déménager en fait en Amérique pour
justement décider de bâtir de nouveau
projet en fait d'écouter ses passions et
moi les patients pour ça extrêmement
intéressant et c'est pour ça que toute
ma vie jusqu'à maintenant j'ai toujours
écouté mes passions mes premières
passions ça a été la psychologie je
trouvais ça tellement intéressant et
même encore aujourd'hui de comprendre le
fonctionnement de l'être humain c'est
penser son mode de vie ou même comment
atteindre ses objectifs avec le
développement personnel et du coup j'ai
beaucoup appris j'ai lu des livres j'ai
écouté des conférences des vidéos dans
le but d'en apprendre un maximum et du
coup j'ai fait ça pendant cinq ans pour
avoir un maximum de connaissances sur ce
sujet peu de temps après ma passion a
pour l'entrepreneuriat il est parce que
je trouve ça super intéressant au-delà
d'un simple succès commercial une
entreprise c'est surtout une solution un
problème c'est surtout faire son maximum
pour que le client soit satisfait et du
coup j'ai vraiment aimé ces deux
passions en faisant en sorte d'en
apprendre un maximum sur ces deux sujets
au début on va dire de ma vie j'ai
commencé en faisant du mannequinat pour
deux agences sur Paris petit à petit
juste après j'ai commencé avec la
création de ma première société
une société qui était axée sur les
vêtements avec un contexte international
parce que pour moi le contexte
international est super important quel
que soit le domaine c'est vraiment ça
qui peut faire la différence du coup
cette société a duré quelques temps et
par la suite j'avais envie de faire
quelque chose de nouveau je me disais
quel défi quoi non c'est qu'est-ce que
je préfère concrètement quelque chose
qui change vraiment et du coup j'ai
toujours été un vecteur régulier au delà
de sous j'ai lu pas mal d'oeuvre
littéraires assez
et du coup je me suis dit pourquoi ne
pas écrire un livre mais sur quel sujet
et
toujours été passionné comme je vous
disais par la psychologie
l'entrepreneuriat du coup je me suis dit
pourquoi ne pas en faire un livre tout
simplement du coup j'ai commencé ce
projet écrivant très régulièrement
faisant en sorte de faire mon maximum
vraiment et du coup au bout de quelques
mois j'ai fini ce premier livre et du
coup je me suis dit Martin qu'est-ce que
fait concrètement c'est quoi la suite et
j'avais cette chance d'avoir un ami qui
était un peu spécialisé à son secteur de
l'édition lui il avait déjà fait
quelques livres et du coup il savait de
quoi il parle beaucoup recommandé et par
la suite j'ai signé un premier contrat
d'édition dans une maison d'édition et
du coup je me disais ça y est en fait
une passion devient réalité au début
j'étais passionné par l'écriture par la
lecture et en fait au fil du temps ce
premier livre est sorti il a été
disponible dans pas mal d'endroits et du
coup je me suis dit c'est vraiment
dingue en fait de réaliser une passion
en partant juste d'une idée par la suite
du coup j'ai continué bien évidemment en
faisant un deuxième et un troisième
livre parce que c'était passionné en
fait et je me suis toujours dit il faut
aller à fond dans ses passions vraiment
et du coup vu que l'écriture c'était
c'est toujours une passion qui perdure
chez moi je me suis dit je me suis dit
au-delà de faire des livres qu'est-ce
que je pourrais faire qui toucherait le
public dans le sens qu'il faut aller
leur apporter véritablement et du coup
j'avais commencé au début en faisant des
articles économiques psychologiques pour
ma première maison d'édition je me suis
dit c'est très intéressant ça peut
apporter mais qu'est-ce que je peux
faire de mieux concrètement et le
développement personnel pour moi c'est
toujours à quelque chose de très
intéressant du coup je me suis dit je
vais faire des interviews de
personnalité je vais cibler des
personnes que absolument tout le monde
connaît pour un parcours qui est
vraiment très intéressant qui véhicule
des valeurs et en fait je vais leur
demander qu'est-ce qui fait qui
réussissent ou non pour eux qu'est-ce
qu'un bonhomme d'affaires quelles sont
les qualités pour aboutir à telle ou tel
projet et en fait mon objectif c'était
de partir au public parce que au final
chacun peut prendre les conseils des
autres et c'est ça qui est justement
très intéressant et du coup j'ai
continué en multipliant un petit peu les
interviews avec
de personnalité que ça soit des hommes
d'affaires ou même des personnalités
dans un secteur un peu plus médiatique
histoire que ça soit très très vaste que
tout le monde se dise tiens ça va être
utile ou ça peut m'apporter ne serait-ce
qu'un tout petit peu et du coup par la
suite j'étais assez inspiré on va dire
d'avoir fait ça et je me suis dit
quelle passion je pourrais écouter parce
que je me disais j'ai déjà réalisé ça et
ça et après quel est quel est le BUT
quelle est la suite du coup par la suite
j'avais beaucoup échangé avec avec des
amis sur qu'est-ce que je pourrais faire
concrètement ou même quelles études
continuer et je réfléchissais je
réfléchissais et je m'étais tourné
justement vers un nouveau projet vous
avez
quelques intéressants du coup j'ai
poursuivi j'ai acheté des informations
et je me suis investi tout simplement
parce que pour moi des fédérations
peuvent apporter beaucoup et du coup au
fil du temps au fil des mois j'ai pu
obtenir des postes et j'ai vu que petit
à petit ça poussait la différence et ce
que ce que je me rends compte c'est que
quand on fait un projet quel que soit le
projet ou même que ça soit de choisir
une filière universitaire d'aller en
école de commerce on est comme
d'ingénieurs de préparer le
Polytechnique comme le frère d'un bon
ami
au final c'est la passion qui est la
variable c'est ça qui fait que vous
allez attendre un projet ou non parce
que si vous êtes passionné vous n'avez
pas la même énergie c'est évident vous
êtes plus investi naturellement vous
êtes plus intéressé et vous vous dites
ça vaut le coup de faire ça parce que
j'ai envie ça peu importe le résultat et
justement au final la seule question
qu'on doit vraiment se poser c'est
quelles sont nos patients qu'est-ce
qu'on a envie de faire vers quelle
banque on a envie de se diriger et
justement c'est un peu le message que je
veux véhiculer à travers ce thème c'est
que chacun dans cette salle vous avez
tous des passions différentes vous avez
des individus différents des objectifs
mais au final le fait d'être passionné
c'est quelque chose d'assez global c'est
c'est un sentiment c'est une énergie on
travaille des matins on a envie de faire
cette chose pas forcément parce que ça
peut nous apporter quelque chose mais
juste parce qu'on dit c'est super
intéressant en fait j'avais envie de le
faire depuis longtemps et que ça soit
par exemple décrire un film que ça soit
de commencer un essai ou même de faire
un article à partir du moment où on se
dit c'est intéressant pour nous ça
m'apporte personnellement mais surtout
ça peut aider les autres personnes c'est
ça qui est super intéressant parce que
au final chacun a un impact et vous
savez j'ai toujours été passionné par
les grands orateurs du coup j'étais très
content de venir TEDx pour écouter tous
ceux qui sont passés bien évidemment et
en fait à chaque fois je me disais
qu'est-ce qu'ils font qui sont là où ils
sont qu'est-ce qu'ils font que par
exemple quelqu'un dans son garage en
Amérique arrive à monter une société
incroyable que tout le monde connaît
alors qu'on soit il est parti de zéro
qui n'était pas forcément prédestiné
pour faire ça on se dit qu'est-ce qu'il
fait c'est ça se trouve c'est un génie
c'est quelqu'un d'incroyable il s'est
absolument tout c'est il a des supers
pouvoirs pas forcément c'est juste que
au final le facteur commun c'est que
chacun est passionné et pour moi chaque
personne qui a un véritable impact quel
que soit l'impact bien sûr c'est la
passion avant tout c'est se dire tiens
je décide de monter une entreprise que
ça soit une entreprise de tech de
communication ou même qui sont en
rapport avec l'environnement je me dis
je suis passionné petit à petit je mets
des actions en place et je vais essayer
de le faire
et du coup pour clôturer ce Ted je
voulais vous dire que c'est la passion
qui forgera votre avenir et que en
mettant en place des actions petit à
petit vous pouvez véritablement avoir un
impact merci à tous